carl said when you first start out with
the red pill and game you're too stupid
to make decisions that's why the various
rules exist by the time you're ready to
get into a relationship get married or
have a kid you should be smart enough to
make that call without asking dudes on
the internet a lot of guys are asking
random dudes on the internet for advice
when they're they're starting from the
wrong position completely
right
yeah let me grab these shots real quick
before they talk about that in in
winning right and uh tim grover talks
about that he says like eventually
you have to get enough consultation you
got to get enough counseling and
advisory
to kind of
re-cultivate your own judgment and then
from there you have to make judgment
calls on your own because like you know
i have people who i hire um as marketing
consultants and people that
you know help me with like opt-in pages
split testing and whatever but at the
end of the day i make the final judgment
call on these things
because you have to like you're the
you're the one that knows your situation
the boat the the best
that's what a lot of these guys
um
don't seem to realize like you can't
like for example right like the rsd
model right they don't they don't teach
you to be
self-sufficient when it comes to chicks
they just bring you out to a boot camp
and they like hype you up and they like
make you like go talk to a lot of girls
they like emotionally charge you there's
a lot of woo-woo soy with those guys
lately man like i
i just stay away from all that yeah and
then what they do is they they get you
all hyped up and then they you know they
they emotionally deceive you in person
right because i met so many rsd guys who
come to me who have spent thousands like
three thousand dollars per boot camp
right jesus and they go to these boot
camps and they're like oh my god i'm so
hyped up i'm so alpha and then like they
go back home and then like you know two
months go by and they're like nothing
really changed they just had like this
highly energized emotional experience
and then they think oh well you know if
i could just go back to this boot camp i
can like get my mojo back and i can do
it yeah those those those boot camp
fields that area is is a total train
wreck because on one side of the
equation you have these losers that will
actually place
paid
prostitutes to make these guys feel like
what they're doing works and we've seen
you produce evidence uh you know very
very conclusive evidence in fact john um
of some real losers that do this we have
guys in our group like troy who's in you
know russian the reason why we're not
seeing him here on these casting for the
last
several saturdays is he busy you know
putting creating content and putting out
and actually you know providing useful
stuff
and those two things can blend and it's
really hard to separate the wheat from
the chaff um let me get these super chat
before we continue we've got julia here
says i think it uh relates to the
immediate question that that's being
asked most men get rp'd through trauma
why did my chick leave for example is
asked for more often than how do i get
into crypto ever will
um
we're going to talk about stuff like
crypto as well because that's one of the
things that came up as well uh cuban
libertarian says entertainment education
and consumption slash production ratios
uh ryan chong at some point everybody
leaves rp once they've gained what they
needed to live their lives the way they
wanted to
let me ask you guys this question
do you guys watch any other channel any
other rp channels i mean
i probably don't watch that much on
youtube to begin with i mean i watch car
videos and i watch sailing videos you
know for the most part now and from time
to time
like ryan's last video that i commented
on that was like guy richie quinton
terentino mashup
i love that like that was hilarious
um that was like two videos ago you
should go watch it on his channel and i
like watching some of john's uh stuff
from time to time when i can carve it
out but i can't watch it live because i
don't have three hours of my day so i'll
wait for the recording then i'll play it
back at like 1.75 speed to kind of like
tear through 45 minutes of the main
stuff do you guys watch other red pill
channels too
very rarely almost no very rarely
no i just started uh
no really like
i feel bad it's not like you're going to
learn anything from me right john
aside from business like we talk about
business stuff i watch your stuff i
watch like your money stuff and um you
know like the most recent one you put on
the rich cooper clips channel five ways
to make a million dollars in 2021 i
watched that um rollo always sends me
videos and i'm like yeah yeah i'll watch
it i just never watch it literally the
top two people i watch on youtube are
you and charlie from cultivate crypto
[Laughter]
that's it
but yeah i know you guys everybody's got
entertaining i don't even watch my own
[ __ ] after i've finished editing it i
can't stand the [ __ ] sight of it to
be fair
what about you fetch do you watch
anything on youtube
uh every once in a while i'll put
something on while i'm lifting um
but a lot of your guys stuff i listen to
uh like uh when i wake up in the morning
and i'm cooking breakfast i usually
catch john's show about halfway through
so i turn it on i'll make some comments
cooking my eggs i'll list them
but uh
not much every once in a while i'll i'll
hit on certain things to see what people
are talking about
you know uh i was watching i did watch
kevin samuels for a couple weeks but
then i realized you know it became the
same show every episode
fresh and fit every once in a while i'll
watch the uh the short clips here and
there but it's like it's again it's the
same
it's the same show it's the same
conversation like myron could be an
animatronic robot saying the same thing
to these girls every time
you